was geht hier soll max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video
ihr seht mich in groß und klein
minecraft das heißt wir beantworten
fragen und ich habe mir außerdem so ein
bisschen amerikanisches zeugs kopf weil
wir haben so ein süßigkeiten laden der
einfach nur amerikanische süßigkeiten
hat bei uns so richtig cool und davon
werde ich mir nebenbei etwas zu gönnen
und ja das war so ein bisschen relaxt
werden bisschen entspannt und joana
meyer einmal gegen eine wand warum bist
du so dumm dass irgendwo auch gar nicht
oder wirklich wirklich dumm geht es war
glaube ich einem schlecht gespielt es
traurig sein zu ich werde probieren das
ist einfach fantastisch
genau ich habe mich mit hashtag erdnuss
traube mir vorstellen dass man das sind
peanuts bei der caps also erdnussbutter
und deshalb heißt der hashtag auch soll
es diesmal sogar einigermaßen sinnvoll
es kommt schon ist kommen die ersten
videos rein okay dafür müssen wir mein
handy herum
guten appetit
alex erst mal einen tipp von dem gruß
des lebens bauleute dieses zeug ist so
unglaublich süß künstlich und pappig das
liebe leoni ist ein sehr komisches video
von dgb schickt mir nicht wieder so was
was an mit oder ohne starkem kohlensäure
ich glaube als starke kohlensäure und
ohne starke kohlensäure kauft wasser
ohne starke kohlensäure unterstützt
durch produktplatzierungen von wasser
ich werde erst mal so ein plakat
probieren ich kenne die risiken aber ich
hatte mich schon mal die caps zeit immer
so so riegel irgendwie für mich sowieso
eine mischung aus spaß und spaß ein spaß
der fragen videos machen dann spaß der
sache macht ich mache euch alle neidisch
hoffentlich fokussiere kag die wurst die
kaki wurst wenig fokussieren
der schwandorfer fokussiere dieses ding
viel schlechter beauty youtuber leute
aber ich habe wenige videos die extrem
herausstechen bin ich persönlich ist da
will ich einfach alles sagen wo ich mir
besonders viel mühe gegeben habe zum
beispiel das wetter im video von gestern
special lp
wie bist du zum rappen gekommen ich muss
jetzt an dieser stelle ein zitieren
sagen ich bin kein rapper nur dass ich
wirklich keiner bin und auch nicht so
tue aber wahrscheinlich wegen den
freezers mit justin ja keine ahnung ich
habe tatsächlich manchmal so mit kumpels
so verfahren wenn wir irgendwie schon
was getrunken haben oder so was für ein
paar ließ haben wir dann irgendwie zur
freestyle
zum spaß und dann hab ich das mal mit
justin gemachten video sie ist eine hexe
verbrennt sie julia schwarz
du musst brennen bislang nein ich habe
eine freundin und das habe ich schon mal
twitter gepostet auf youtube auch schon
den einen oder anderen videos gesagt und
ja hab ich habe eine freundin
okay leute das wird langsam bisschen zu
abgefragt ich hab gesagt schickt mir
fragen oder dumme dinge und luca hat
euch alles öko brainwash dass ihr nur
noch verrücktere videos macht luca was
tust du für sachen naja ballade von tief
oder soll ich mal ein bisschen weiter so
tief reden höre ich mich ja schon
anbieten musste die erdnüsse sind nicht
aus erde kommen wir zum nächsten mal mit
der nächsten frage weiter würdest du
einen elefanten sterben oder eine brot
ohne kruste essen brot ohne kruste
wahrscheinlich wobei von elefanten
sterben leute ich hab gleich fragen oder
dürfen dinge keine dummen fragen
da habt ihr was falsch verstanden
hashtag #tatort ins special
denn so schlägt ich kann das gar nicht
dafür kann ich andere coole dinge zum
einen
und ich kann so trillerpfeifen das
klingt als würde ich sterben weil ich
schon länger nicht mehr gemacht habe ja
leute ich würde sagen das war's von
diesem video dass so viele fragen kommen
das fand ich wirklich neues ich hoffe
mal dass ich was hoffe ich hoffe ihr
habt auch was lasst doch mal ein like in
den kommenden 6